pure joy
pure joy is the way that Rolling Stone
describes
the emotional circumstances among
staffers at Fox News over the firing of
propagandist Tucker Carlson this is just
delightful to see
Fox News and Tucker Carlson have parted
ways he's been fired the rest of the
network seems thrilled writes this
Rolling Stone article quote pure joy one
fox reporter told Rolling Stone of their
reaction to the split no one is
Untouchable it's a great day for America
and for the real journalists who work
hard every day to deliver the news at
Fox okay I don't know how many of them
there are a producer added quote it was
a good move to part ways with Tucker he
knowingly spread lies throughout his
time at Fox but I fear management will
replace him with someone who is just
like him so there probably won't be any
real change as I suggested earlier in
the show a network correspondent said
quote good riddance for a while there it
seemed like he was running the network
this clearly is a message that he's not
in the interim it's a morale boost for
sure so a lot of people at Fox happy
with this this decision and I think it's
is important to again insert into this
discussion
there is no reason whatsoever to believe
that Tucker Carlson was fired because
his on-air message became incompatible
with the ideology of Fox News everything
we know is that these are all really
sort of like Personnel and legal issues
Tucker Carlson
fomented the story lines that got Fox
News sued by Dominion
and paying out almost 800 million
dollars and currently under lawsuit by
smartmatic potentially paying out even
more money Tucker was part of that
Tucker was attacking Fox Management in
text messages which we learned about
because of that lawsuit Tucker and
alleged harassment taking place in his
staff among his staff environment uh it
has now led to a lawsuit by a woman and
the targeting of Ray Epps may lead to
another lawsuit against Tucker Carlson
and his program so he became a legal
problem he became a headache he became a
problem employee essentially but it is
not because Fox News decided oh we
really shouldn't have that ideology
needless to say the fact that fox
staffers are so thrilled about this is
fascinating another article from the LA
Times writes Tucker Carlson producers
discrimination claims go beyond Dominion
scandal
this is uh and I just lost the article I
don't know where it went Abby grossberg
sued Fox Fox News Tucker and several
producers late yesterday alleging the
network is Rife with sexist misogynistic
and abusive Behavior there are people
already saying that none of these
allegations are true and there are
people saying obviously they are we have
a lawsuit it's going to be adjudicated
okay but the lawsuit is another problem
a grossberg's lawsuit alleges
discrimination based on gender religion
and disability she alleges that quote
constant bullying and gaslighting caused
her quote so much stress and anxiety
that her stomach ulcers flared up and
she was in excruciating pain so that is
going to be investigated that is going
to be looked at and then of course we
have the potentially forthcoming lawsuit
from Ray Epps not good for Fox News it
was not mutual Tucker was fired but if
anybody is happy here other than
millions of Americans who rightly assess
that Tucker was damaging the country it
is Fox News staffers themselves pure joy
the exact quote from Rolling Stone good
habits have to be sustainable something
you'll actually stick to I start my
mornings with a scoop of ag-1 by our
sponsor athletic greens because it's
just so simple one scoop of ag-1 gives
me the entire day's worth of 75 high
quality vitamins and minerals from whole
food sources half of Americans are
deficient in vitamin A C and magnesium
taking that scoop of ag-1 makes sure
that I'm getting the nutrients I want
without fumbling with different capsules
and dosages and all of these things ag1
is also way more cost effective than
buying all of those different vitamins I
drink ag1 straight with water because I
like the taste but but you could put it
in a smoothie a juice a protein shake I
would not promote bogus supplements
making crazy claims there's no crazy
claims here ag1 is just a simple product
it does what it says it does it helps me
get what I want to get every day and
when you go to athleticgreens.com Pacman
you will get a free year supply of
vitamin D plus five free travel packs of
ag1 I've talked about vitamin D before
the link is down below